hello everybody and welcome to part 11
of let's play nightmare house - all
right we discovered basically everything
there is to discover in this place we
found out that the wife's name is Emily
and the house they had when they were a
happy couple was the house where the
nightmare house was house house house
house house house okay move it on I
think we're getting close to the end I
am so ready to bury this axe in Billy's
face the jerk you broke down this okay
oh hello looks like they're loading me
up with ammo oh so ready Oh big arrow
pointing me in the right direction
thank you Oh No hello boom no banging
table broke your box Billy what do you
think about that all right fine get out
of here oh hey hey Billy beautiful
that's all I'll just just go back there
I just lost civilization mr. Boatwright
Daryl is to try to control oh that's
nice borrow
on occasions I will associate oh yes one
more time uh-huh right now I can't
really control your everyday
for example oh yeah bring it hi oh hello
ah come on really huh boom I got here
boom yeah Spanky oh come on where's the
kill I get here whoa Master that's
always great experience
uh-huh yeah whatever man I'll get out of
here oh oh oh shut up
f you man Oh Sparky we got aa
oh yeah oh I'm touched of our wrongs mom
this is so out yeah whatever
boom there we go all right what else we
got flashes of blue I'm sure that
Billy's up there can you get up there Oh
everybody everybody I wonder what this
switch does yeah yeah take that
boom man all right what do we got here
[Music]
well that was cool
not
oh here I know oh yeah I'm sure they are
I got here whoa I went for I went for a
boob hole bring it on yeah sure you are
note to self shotguns ineffective
against wood for some reason hi yeah
there we go
ah you cut it out with your stupidness I
call you Oh take that ah to help get out
of here Oh
kicking your ass nice job supporting
this thing with flimsy beams of wood Oh
smart job there homeboy
yeah no no no yes I am are you mad Oh
onde phoned his goon
come on did I get it
ah I need help getting out of here uh
dead Oh dead
um need help need help need help
and held over here
Oh oh yeah totally come on come on ah
give me give me give me give me ah give
me give me give me up [ __ ] you
I said give me I got here okay here I'm
a tough luck get out of here I get out
of here get out of here
now that wasn't help Oh give me help
please
Oh screw it screw it I'm just finishing
it great I can do this yeah Oh get the
[ __ ] out of my world huh oh no no you
can't fail now I can't fail now can't
bail now
ah I'm gonna win can't stop me on to
meet Afro dodge Boom Bang II arrived
nope
I have lots of friends yeah no kidding
do you think I'm doing I'm gonna let you
keep doing that time to save you
somewhere else
what oh hello Oh get it hi oh yeah
thank you lady oh oh come give me my
reward oh yeah oh yeah oh I think I will
let me at it let me at it
Oh aa dagger damn it
ah I'm bad secretly you all you guys
thought I was good very last sucka games
can't shoot worth a damn Oh
the name is markiplier learn some more
serious no ah
alright almost got it come on oh yes I
can
please she's my lady now hello ha oh
they're all you know oh yeah I thought
so yep uh-huh
yay a way out huh
no no no Oh was that a mannequin oh no
mannequin I didn't know they could do
reflects okay okay ah no no no no no no
no no hell no yeah come on all right
Oh Oh get out here get out of here Oh
get out of here
okay let me out let me out let me ha ha
Oh screw you oh come on guys oh my god
oh no oh no okay okay all right all
right I'm back yeah I can
oh I'm ready I'm ready
you just don't get it uh-huh she's using
you yeah nerd game
whatever man she likes me all right come
on face this was seven health all yeah
oh just try it oh did you see me bro own
that guy oh stop uh-huh I won't need to
stop her I'll let her go she died give
me out here
Oh what is going on Oh what the hell ah
good Oh what am i doing when I can't
move what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] I can't move what's going on I
can't even move alright finally the hell
was that all of it ah alright alright
I'm not supposed to go that way
obviously whatever oh hello baby
yeah oh thank you ah I like her alright
that was nothing nothing
Oh trippy okay what's going on all right
Oh
okay hello oh I get it
that makes sense yep
of course they thought I was insane she
sent you all the way here uh-huh
don't you understand
it was an accident
well she came to help now makes you
close to the boring here
just give up nope I don't think I will
ah hey put down the shield bro there we
just using you to get
aha whatever oh you're done oh you're
done yeah oh yeah
I'm the man Yuda loser oh yeah I win you
lose give me my reward uh-huh yeah yeah
yeah sounds about right
hey belly how's it going I'm just gonna
lay here leave
I think that's operational order you're
looking for Oh loser oh oh yeah uh-huh
no she's not back for you I'm sorry for
everything that's happened no you're not
sorry for everything I had nope uh-huh
yeah
oh yeah get him ha oh yeah uh-huh
we go Billy go how are you still alive
after that yeah all right that did it I
think he's dead now hello baby
you're welcome wait where's my reward
uh-huh darn it oh well anyway
oh man for a mod for just a mod that was
amazing if it were a real game I would
have paid money for that like seriously
that guy it was like ten bucks I woulda
bought it bought no question so man that
was awesome I hope you all enjoyed it
and man you got to go out and play it
right now I know a lot of you already
own half-life and half-life 2 half-life
episode two probably big fans of it
already if you like in gaming of any
soil even we've heard of it so it's real
cheap on Steam go buy that get the mod
it's phenomenal and if you've never
played have like to then go ahead and
play it
it's amazing anyway um once again I have
to thank everyone every one of you who
is subscribed to me given me your
support I I really can't believe that
you guys have taken to my videos so well
I just started it out as a whim like I
thought it'd be cool an interesting idea
and it's turned into something bigger
[Music]
it's bigger than I ever expected it to
be so I'm still dedicated to five to six
videos every single day every single day
and then they seem like a lot to you but
I'm really dedicated to giving you
everything that you want and helping the
channel grow so I've also set up my a
Facebook page and a Twitter account I've
never used Twitter in my life but I set
one up the links are available on my
channel on the right sidebar thank you
guys so much and I'm gonna be in this
for the long haul I'm gonna be doing new
games I'm gonna finish up to number a
Requiem I'm gonna move on I think I'm
gonna play Dead Island and I've got
quite a few more on my list and I've got
a special project that I think you're
all gonna like and well I can't really
say any more about but you'll see it
soon thank you guys so much bye-bye